l'équipe seniors du rugby club de
versets réalisé la bonne opération de
cette 13ème journée de fédérale 3 à la
lutte pour le maintien les bleus ont
décroché une précieuse victoire à
domicile ce dimanche contre pitivi
l'équipe qui lutte également pour ne pas
descendre le score vincent
on va dire que c'est une belle victoire
parce qu'avec tard à celle des tripes
c'était un adversaire finalement que
s'est avéré difficile avec un jeu au
pied très très très gênant c'était
compliqué on marque on march sera le
premier c'était dur voilà après on
marque un deuxième et là on les enfonce
on n'a pas le bonus mais au moins on
fait un bon match c'est mérité en tout
cas pour toute l'équipe
les coaches bien verstraete a été l'un
des hommes clés de la rencontre de
retour dans le groupe pour cette
deuxième partie de saison après six mois
passés dans le sud de la france à
tournefeuille le versailles et formé au
club apporte s'inviter dans les phases
offensives
tu voulais jouer avec les copains
c'était ça fait plaisir de revenir voilà
c'est mes potes d'enfance donc c'est un
plaisir de gagner ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est un enfant du club et
quand on voit un enfant du club qui
revient chez nous et qu à la hargne à ce
point pour sortir le club des
difficultés si le plus belles choses
qu'on puisse dire quand on est un club
formateur on est très contents de la
voir ça un retour un retour très
satisfaisant pour l'équipe pour le
groupe
versailles pointe désormais à un point
du premier non relégable
une victoire le dimanche 28 février
contre courbevoie pourrait permettre aux
joueurs de la cité royale de se
rapprocher du maintien
l'histoire continue et la saison n'est
pas finie